le commandant massoud chef militaire de
l'opposition talibans afghans est à
paris il a été reçu à l'assemblée
nationale et au quai d'orsay par le
ministre hubert védrine le commandant
massoud en situation très précaire face
aux talibans a besoin de l'aide
occidentale
commentaire de retenir etc avec gilles
jacquier
hier encore le commandant massoud était
dans ses chères montagnes afghanes
aujourd'hui il se fraie un chemin dans
la meute
il est pour la première fois de sa vie a
pas l'homme qui monte dans la voiture
blindée est un mythe vivant héros
légendaire de la résistance à l'invasion
soviétique
il se bat aujourd'hui contre les taliban
qui règne sur 95% de l'atelier pour
cette première visite en europe le
commandant massoud a été reçu pendant
une heure par le ministre des affaires
étrangères et par le ministre de la
coopération
à l'issue de l'entretien hubert védrine
a annoncé l'envoi d'une nouvelle aide
française aux populations afghanes
interrogé sur le type d'appui politique
ou militaire qu'il attendait de
l'occident le commandant massoud n'a pas
répondu directement
la fin de la guerre en afghanistan est
dans les mains de la communauté
internationale qui doit exercer de
fortes pressions sur le pakistan le
pakistan qui soutient le mouvement
fondamentaliste des talibans n'a pas été
mentionnée par le président de
l'assemblée nationale ni par aucun des
hommes politiques rencontrées
aujourd'hui par le commando marine
je veux que la france plus de son
influence pour rétablir la paix en
afghanistan
lapret en afghanistan cela fait plus de
vingt ans coude au commandant massoud en
rêve et pourtant de guerre en guerre ce
but qu'on appelle là-bas le lion du
panchir dispose chaque année de moins en
moins deux combattants
aujourd'hui il serait 20000 face aux
talibans